[Music]
hi everyone thank you all for coming
great to see so many people here my name
is Oscar I am from the developer
relations team and today we're going to
speak about camera in this session we'll
cover three major topics first we're
going to talk about the inner workings
of camera on Android second Snap is here
with us today they're gonna showcase how
they use the camera API in production to
millions of users we're gonna close with
our vision of the future of how camera
API should evolve and the ecosystem that
goes with it let's jump right in
developing camera app is a series of
compromises some are outside of your
control
as a developer but understanding those
will help you make better decisions
where you have control within your app
let's cover how camera works at the
physical level as any decent
photographer knows it is a pipeline of
steps at the physical level visible
light goes to a lens that directs it to
filters which passes the light on to
millions of light sensors then that
converts the light finally into a 2d
matrix of pixels when you think light
sensors the first thing that may come to
mind is the all-mighty CCD nowadays we
have many other kinds such as CMOS or
ApS that are actually more commonly used
in today's modern cameras DSLRs phones
etc from now on we refer to this
component as the camera module the
output of the camera module is a raw
picture a raw frame it is not entirely
unprocessed but it has not been
processed outside of the camera module
at this stage you can think of the
camera module as a black box that
dispatches these frames in early
hardware we had three physical pins for
different kinds of pic
nowadays modern designs we have a single
pin thanks to tricks like multiplexing
and higher clock speeds and so forth but
the conceptual model remains as having
separate processing pipelines for each
kind of image we have generally speaking
three broad use cases video preview
photo and video recording will cover
those separately the camera module as I
said is a black box and it contains an
increasing amount of smarts within some
of which are in a closed feedback loop
you as a developer which developers will
have very little visibility into what
goes on in there to give you an example
when you set say auto focus or auto
white balance the camera module may be
looking for faces to see how to better
optimize those settings and you don't
really have any control over that from a
framework standpoint all developers do
is send one configuration in and you get
one frame out this is very very
important you send one configuration in
one frame out for each frame there is a
configuration that goes with it to help
you with this we have a set of template
configurations we'll cover those later
as well
so let's zoom into the preview pipeline
the one on top as I said each pipeline
shown is a broad use case when it comes
to preview you can think of it as the
viewfinder so whenever somebody is
holding their phone up and you want to
see what the camera sees this is the use
case we are talking about
we need to compromise on some things
obviously the camera can only do so many
things at once when it comes to preview
we choose to compromise on quality we
care much more about latency we want the
user to be able to see what the camera
see is much faster this is just general
results in better latency because we're
able to compromise as I said on quality
some of those compromises come in the
form of for example reduce motion
stabilization or less noise reduction
moving on to the photo pipeline you may
want to enable our users to capture
high-quality images keep in mind that as
I said before one frame configures and
in one person in one frame out different
frame configuration may mean that you
will not be able to reuse the same raw
frame one example of this is if you are
requesting different exposure so at the
physical level the sensor ministers post
the frame for a different period of time
that means that you're gonna have a
different frame entirely if you are
mindful while you set up your pipelines
you may be able to avoid this compromise
entirely so when it comes to photos we
care much more about the quality a lot
less about the speed so we choose to
compromise on that latency in little of
having much better quality image lastly
we have the video pipeline this is for
the video record use case as the diagram
indicates you're seeing that all these
pipelines should be parallel in theory
in practice we have a number of Bilal
necks and frames can only come so fast
out of the camera some of those
bottlenecks include the exposure time
some of them can be the processing power
memory bandwidth limits a number of
other things in the video pipeline is
almost a blend of the previous two we
care about the speed we definitely need
to have frames coming consistently out
of the camera at a certain rate but at
the same time we also care about quality
so it is very important that in this
kind of this case we find the right
balance
generally speaking we can only test for
so many things Android runs in many many
devices not just the high end but you're
talking about low end to unfortunately
we can only test and say so many things
in general the best test that a scenario
is when you have preview pipeline
running plus one other you're gonna have
a really hard time if you want to have
all three pipelines running
simultaneously so we discussed
trade-offs made by the hardware we
discussed trade-offs made by the
framework and now we're gonna dive into
the application layer what we as
developers can do let's walk to the
end-to-end process of a frame from the
creation of a request until the pictures
are finally memory ready for us to use
follow the steps ICS ABC and then profit
all just fall on your lap you don't
believe me ask not yet the first
decision you have to make as a developer
is selecting the right device out of the
ones available in your list device here
means the camera module not devices in
phone device each phone may have
multiple cameras generally speaking you
probably have this one front one back
this is especially important now that we
have multi camera api's you may have
multiple devices that are say back
facing that you can choose from so
you'll have to go through those devices
and see which one fits your use case
best once you've successfully open the
camera you're gonna get the camera
device instance and that is necessary to
proceed forward in the open camera
callback you can use the very same code
right to monitor the status of your
camera device it is entirely possible
that the camera may be yanked from you
if a higher priority process requires
the device this could happen very easily
in a multi window environment for
example second step you need to allocate
your camera output targets this is where
each of the pipelines that we shot
earlier are gonna copy your frames in
the form of buffers
the memory may already be allocated then
all you need to do is to get a reference
to the underlying surface and pass it as
a target
otherwise you may have to wait for a
callback once the targets are ready the
capture session which is specific to the
device that you open can be created it
is worth noting that as I said the
camera capture session is specific to
that device that you open earlier once
the session is ready you can build a
capture request one of the predefined
templates must be used if you don't want
to take any of the hints from the system
you can use template manual for full
control otherwise the framework is going
to provide a set of templates that
closely align to the camera conceptual
model we discussed earlier so you have
templates for preview you have templates
for photo and your templates for record
the capture request contains specific
frame configuration and the output
target recall frame configuration in
Apple Fame out a couple of things to
know is the output target must be one of
the previously defined ones you cannot
just use another surface here and attach
it in is to be one of the surfaces that
you declared first as part of the
session this is the configuration part
of it of the configuration in frame at
to recap we've chosen the camera the
last that we want we create the camera
assistant for that particular device and
now we built a capture request that will
be used in that session we can finally
ask for a camera frame we send the
capture request to the session and then
we vote for the callback we can do this
in two ways we can send a request once
and we can make it repeat any request
this makes more sense in use cases like
for example preview or video record you
don't want to be sending a configuration
for every single frame this is a very
easy way to just send one configuration
and ask the framework to continuously
repeat it now which callback that you
want to listen to that really depends on
what you want to get out of it if you
want to get the frame metadata
you should look inside of the capture
callback if you want to get the frame
for CPU processing one of the options is
using image reader generally speaking
you can just get whatever pixel
information out of the upper surface
that you have set up imagery there's
just one of the easiest ways to do it if
you want to get that into the GPU a
great idea is using renderscript
allocations obviously that's not the
only choice you can also use OpenGL
texture buffers and this is the cycle
step one through five that we need to go
through for every single frame recall
one configuration in one frame out and a
bunch of trade-offs in the process
alright thanks Oscar
my name is Mustafa Brar I'm a software
engineer at Snap and so I work on the
snapchat app today what I want to do is
take what Oscar said about the lower
layers of the camera and sort of work up
to your app and design choices that you
make and how they influence how you
interact with the camera we'll talk
about some trade-offs in terms of
architecture how to architect the camera
framework inside of your app and we'll
talk about specific challenges in sort
of a more narrow use case so nowadays if
you've ever used snapchat I'm hoping
everyone has the first thing that
happens is it opens directly into the
camera and the reason for this is that
people use the camera now as a means of
communication they're taking a picture
they're adding metadata creativity and
then sending it and so it's really like
the cursor where what do you have to say
and trying to get that out as quickly as
possible it's sort of the thing we
really value there are a few key camera
design decisions that we've made and
these will influence how we interact
with the camera the first of those is
fullscreen in video in pictures front
camera rear camera all of them are full
screen now you typically don't see this
on a lot of cameras if you take your
camera out usually picture mode is four
by three aspect ratio because a lot of
times you share
online the camera actually optimized for
specific aspect ratios and so since your
display is usually you know sixteen by
nine or some other aspect ratio that
might not you know be available for
picture mode we have to make a trade-off
usually the devices will have something
that matches but it might be really high
resolution and to just encode that and
create a JPEG out of it just takes a
long time so we have to make trade-offs
in terms of the resolution we select for
taking pictures and video and so forth
the second part is single mode there's
no video mode you can you don't swipe
and enter a video mode and when you have
this design choice it leads to a set of
optimizations you can't take advantage
for example videos there's a recording
hint on Android that you can tell the
system the user is about to report
there's a lot of optimizations that you
can set but if you don't know the user's
intent if they long press it's a video
if they just take a picture single tap
you don't know ahead so you can't decide
upfront what configurations are always
gonna work we try to do static
configurations that are good in a lot of
scenarios and then we have certain that
are dynamic and we update those
depending on what the user's intent is
the other part is for a long time
snapchat has offered lenses a lot of
interactive features inside of the
camera and each of those things
forces certain trade-offs for example if
there's a lot of motion your face is
moving and you're trying to track a
user's face optical image stabilization
there's a lot of things that might not
work well with these other things that
want to keep track of where the user is
also it has a lot of memory overhead
there's a lot of GPU work going on and
you need to balance all the work that
you do the last part is you can't cheat
you have to capture the picture in front
of the users so they can get their
message out as fast as possible most
cameras if you take a picture it hides
the latency and it saves it in the
background so you don't see it it just
kind of falls away and you don't really
see how long it actually takes but for
us because the real meet is when users
edit the canvas of their image or their
a video we have to do it right there and
then it's and so you have to make
certain trade-offs to have lit low
latency to get there now too
support these and some other features
you need to kind of think about how the
overall architecture of your app is
gonna be if you truly want it to be
Universal so there's a few best
practices that I'll share some of them
really just sort of help them broaden
the width of devices that you're able to
target and also how well they perform on
those devices and you know over time
you're gonna add features lenses
interaction so you want a framework
that's extensible so that you could plug
and play different things so the first
thing you have to interact with is the
API that Oscar mentioned it's the part
you interact with the camera and there's
a set of api's there's two versions
there's camera one and it's been around
for many years and then there's also
camera to a newer API
although camera one is deprecated you
know when you have hundreds of millions
of users it's it's big chunk that's
still on camera one so you need to
support it regardless of what the what
the device says the second part is
there's different modes for camera two
for OEMs to slowly adapt they have a
legacy mode which is simply you know
we've made our API work but under the
hood it's really camera one and also
camera two varies by device some devices
say yep camera two works great here but
in reality deep down it's still camera
one and so the performance you get my
very even across devices so you really
need to know each of the different
products that you want to target and so
what we do is we support both since 2016
we've written both camera one and camera
two in terms of code and then what we do
is we add a layer on top that's
basically what our application sees to
just unify what it looks like underneath
and then if you have shared code for
example a picking resolution it doesn't
really matter which version you're using
the logic for the full screen that I
mentioned can be shared by both so
there's some shared code but the
application deals with the top part the
next part is there's millions of devices
a lot of them have bugs they say they
support a certain feature it doesn't
work you zoom in beyond 99% somebod
comes so we have a lot of configuration
that allows us to decide on specific
devices and models what behavior what
configuration to adopt and so this
remote can
aggression is really key and over time
you have to groom it you have to
maintain it it's a very key part of
something that's just code now let's
build up this architecture so I've
talked a bit about sort of the camera
interaction the code that talks to the
camera server which is the Android
system process that manages the camera
and it talks through binder IPC which is
a form of inter process communication
but if you expose this to your
applications it's a little too raw
because you might have a video chat
feature a camera and video note and if
they all try to talk to the camera they
could do things that sort of conflict
with each other there's life cycling a
lot of things you need to be aware of
and so what we do is we have a cue an
operation cue that allows us to coalesce
things that are redundant allows us to
manage sort of invalid
States and so we avoid a lot of
conflicting things across features by
having an operation cue and a thread
that processes them and the next part is
so everything on your right the grey
side is really about the UI you know
like the the shutter button you see the
autofocus the animations all that and
then it has a state machine that says ok
the user tap to autofocus let's do the
animation let's ask the camera to
autofocus the and then it saves your
intent in memory and tries to drive the
asynchronous process to get it done and
so the right-hand side and the left-hand
side have sort of different
responsibilities and then over time your
surface comes in
that's the preview frames that Oscar was
saying it starts showing up on your
screen if you have interactive features
enabled like lenses they get composited
on top of it and this is done in OpenGL
and we try to do it synchronously and
not avoid copying anything large and
then ultimately your UI is composited on
top and so as far as the user is
concerned it all looks integrated but in
reality it's multiple layers that are
coming together now if you look at this
architecture what you notice is that the
left and the right have sort of
different things that you're concerned
about and one way to think about it is
client-server architecture the
right-hand side is like the client the
left hand side is your runtime your
processing and the concerns are
different so from a performance
perspective
the left-hand side needs to worry about
processing frames really fast it needs
to worry about stability a lot of things
and the right-hand side is really about
animations you know new features a lot
of the candy in terms of how the user
interacts with the camera and so one
cool thing you can do is if you ever
work with client server is sometimes the
server slow you know six hundreds of
milliseconds sometimes some issues so
what we do is we have ways of replacing
components you can use dagger you have
other approaches where you say okay
let's just abstract out the camera so
that the UI thinks it's talking to the
real thing and we'll just mock the api's
to the Android system and maybe do an
OAuth or send black frames whatever we
want to do and one place where we take
advantage of this is performance testing
so for example if you add new UI logic
and you want to see if it regresses the
camera anyway you don't care how long
the camera operations take and because
they're variable if let's say takes a
hundred milliseconds to open the camera
and it's variable because it's a system
service then over time you might not be
able to catch ten millisecond
regressions and so in this example here
what I'm showing is a startup regression
test with a mock camera so the camera
has been mocked out it's starting the
app repeatedly and saying okay let's
collect the metrics and see how long
it's taking to get to a stable point and
then we can actually catch regressions
across several commits to see you know
what change might have caused it another
example is instead of replacing the
whole camera you can replace part of it
you could say the frames that are coming
out let's just replace them with
something else rather than the whole
camera you could keep other
functionality intact and so in this case
here we could replace the frames with a
video file and so this is very useful in
situations where let's say you're
automatically testing your face tracking
in the lab environment where you run
integration tests
there's no faces there's no people in
the lab to look at the camera and so
what we do is we actually use the video
files to drive that interaction so
here's a picture of me running some
lenses testing where the frames have
been mocked out from a video file and so
there's me hello I
and you can see the paper showing it's
not the camera it's just a video but
everything else is really it took a snap
it edits it it does a lot of things so
you can mock out parts of the camera to
allow you to add new features and just
test things in isolation and so this is
kind of in terms of an architecture it's
one way to do it there's many ways but
this gives you the performance
considerations on the Left the remote
configuration to get a wide range of
devices supported that have different
cameras multiple cameras nope like
front-facing rear and so the remote
configurations for that the performance
considerations in the UI and the
extensibility now let's jump into a
specific use case snapchats known the
majority of our media is just images and
everyone always asks well how do you
guys take photos how does it all work
and we break it up into several stages
the first stage is capturing quickly
capturing the content so that you can
actually process it and allow the user
to be creative once they're at all their
creatives you composite all of the
different layers of creativity that
they've done and you transcode it into
something that is efficient to transport
over the network to the recipient and
the last part is rendering that's the
part where the recipient looks at the
content and depending on the choices you
make in your player can really affect
the quality of the images that they see
and all of these are complicated things
and we have teams dedicated to each one
but I'll just touch on the capturing one
for today now Oscar mentioned you tell
the camera hey capture a frame and you
wait back and your callback is called
but there's a lot of latency involved in
this step in camera one the API is
called take picture and it takes 400
milliseconds on a really high-end phone
from last year whereas if you take the
preview frame that's optimized for low
latency it's an order of magnitude
smaller and you can see the p90s are
quite high and so what we do is
periodically will optimize as much as we
can our code for specific devices that
we feel are you know pretty good latency
and we enable it remotely for users on
those devices and users are delighted
Wow the quality went up it looks really
cool it just happened today people
notice it right away
but also they notice the delay and if
you're trying to communicate and there's
any lag or anything you'll notice it
right away and so what we do is we try
to do a trade off we do both we'll take
picture and screenshot on certain
devices and if it takes too long we fall
back to the screenshot so we have a lot
of tricks to sort of work around this
you can see examples here where the
quality when you really zoom in is
noticeable but it's not always a
slam-dunk in this case here take a
picture on the left is causing noise and
sometimes the algorithms might
overcompensate and you will see
speckling so it's not always just turn
it on certain front-facing cameras we
disable it even though it can sometimes
result in higher quality especially in
low-light conditions so we balance that
and so really it's a higher key of
trade-offs oskar talked about the low
level you've got the design choices of
what you decided in your application and
ultimately user intent is the user
sending a picture to someone that's
disappearing and you want a favor
latency versus is the user preserving
something so hopefully some of the tips
we've shared will help you guys build a
better camera app thank you
thanks Mustapha hi everyone my name is
Veneto
on the Android camera platform p.m.
Oscar earlier identified a series of
trade-offs required to use the camera to
api's mustafa further elaborated on that
theme on how they applied those
trade-offs in the real world situations
I'm gonna change the conversation a bit
and talk about how working together we
can truly elevate both the developer and
the end-user experience the camera is
evolving today it's moved on from mere
photography as an immersive medium a
great example of this is what was
demonstrated in the keynote by partner
where the camera is now used to do geo
navigation in addition cameras are
everywhere today from IOT devices
there's a great example in the Android
things booth - your laptops - multiple
cameras on devices and that's a trend
that I want you all to take away multi
devices with more than two cameras are
becoming the norm
recall that the camera model that Oscar
talked about earlier in the talk how do
you extend that model in a multi camera
situation let's walk through an example
imagine a device with three back cameras
the native camera app today has access
to the physical streams from each of
these sensors in addition the native
camera app has something called the
logical camera this is a virtual camera
it's made up of all the physical sensors
it is a combined fused stream and it
takes care of some of the trade-offs
that Oscar and Mustafa alluded to in
terms of power performance and latency
so in the native camera app you actually
have four cameras one virtual three
physical in a three camera device but as
developers you only get access to one of
them this is often depends on the
different types of devices and in this
case
you end up making trade-offs you're
using the api's differently from the
native camera app so we're pleased to
announce that starting with Android P
you'll get access to all the cameras
from the logical camera to all the
physical streams this applies to both
the front and back sensors as well as
all many different form factors here's
some example use cases the lady on the
in the picture this is an image of a
bulky mode you can use this new multi
camera API for depth optical vision
getting monochrome frames directly from
the sensor and many more but most of all
we're excited of the use cases that you
guys are gonna build so let's walk
through this API real quick the first
thing you would do is check the camera
characteristics and check if the device
supports the logical multi camera API
next you would check to see which
physical cameras make up this logical
device today we start support by four
RGB and monochrome and we're looking to
add more here it gets very interesting
when you have a logical camera that is
abstracting one front and one back
sensor finally you would check to see if
the frames from all of these sensors are
synchronized so I know what you're
thinking great new API which devices
will support it is it worth your time to
invest in this new API the answer is yes
starting with Android P all new devices
will support this new API and we're
working with many partners to ensure
that upgrade devices also support this
API so let me call out a few partners we
worked very closely the fall way to
ensure that monochrome sensors are
supported they actually helped us test
this API we worked with Xiaomi to ensure
that a majority of their devices support
this API as well so later this year
you'll see devices from both Huawei and
show me supporting this new multi camera
API on upgraded new devices and finally
the Android one team we
worked with manufacturers from this team
to ensure that this API is works across
all tiers of Android and is not
exclusive to just the high tier I want
to share that together we really can
elevate the camera experience working
with you our partners our manufacturers
we're really trying to make sure that we
can bring amazing experiences and most
of all we're very excited to see what
you're gonna build with these new ap
eyes and knowing what trade offs you
need to make using these ap eyes we'd
love to continue the conversation in the
after session meeting space and thank
you Oscar and Mustapha for sharing their
insights
thank you snap for giving a glimpse on
how millions of users get a delightful
experience thank you everyone for
attending enjoy IO
[Applause]
[Music]
you